what actually appears to be completely
doctored relates to the voter
registration of Donald Trump's new
campaign co manager Steve Bannon this is
the Breitbart new CEO who is now the
co-manager of Donald Trump's campaign
Steve Bannon is registered to vote in
the very important swing state of
Florida at an empty house that he
doesn't even live in and he has an
active voter registration at a house in
Miami Dade County Florida the house is
vacant and reportedly set to be
demolished to make way for a new real
estate development this would be a
breach of election law according to
Lewis Guevara the owner of the house I
have emptied the property nobody lives
there we are going to make a
construction there neighbors say the
property has been abandoned for several
months and there's a very weird sort of
backstory about this property where
Bannon used to rent the house for use by
his ex-wife Diane Chloe see but didn't
live there himself Chloe see in her own
right is a tea party activists who moved
out of the house earlier this year she
hasn't an irregular voting pattern
herself to to be discussed maybe on a
different day questions have been asked
to Steve Bannon to Chloe see to the
Trump campaign repeatedly about what is
going on with Steve Bannon being
registered at a house that is vacant and
due to be demolished for construction
absolutely no commentary whatsoever we
did hear from Jason Miller a trump
campaign spokesman who said that mr.
Bannon move to another location in
Florida but is refusing to answer any
other questions whatsoever there are
layers to this insanity number one Steve
Bannon is the CEO of Breitbart news
which for years has been claiming that
minorities and Democrats are just
rampant with voter fraud people voting
plus two times dead people voting people
voting with fake addresses people voting
under fake names etc etc etc so if
bright
Bart muses CEO is doing the exact same
thing that's amazing number one but it
goes even further than that is the Trump
campaign has been running by scaring
other people about how the election is
rigged rigged in a whole variety of ways
and it turns out that Steve Bannon may
not even be entitled to vote in Florida
at all never mind that this particular
address under Florida law voters must be
legal residents of the state and county
where they are intending to register to
vote and it's not even clear what state
Steve Bannon actually lives in it's not
clear if its new york state that he
should actually be voting in or
washington DC or California he has all
sorts of connections to all of those
states but every indication that this
may be someone actually committing voter
fraud the type of fraud that we are told
brown people and Democrats commit uh
truly stunning I mean we've talked Jason
now Trump accuses Hillary of being the
bigot well he's really running the
bigoted in xenophobic campaign Trump
says we need to see Hillary's health
records it turns out that his medical
letter was written in five minutes
specifically by dr. Harold bornstein to
please the Donald Trump campaign most
accusations that Trump is making against
either Democrats or Hillary Clinton or
non-white people are allegations that
are better turned around and applied to
either his own campaign or people
associated with it I think the only
answer here is I'm gonna go to Florida
I'm a rental double-wide I think this is
gonna rent the one next to me we both
get some letters written by some doctors
no not gonna stoop this level i'm just
gonna vote in the state in the county
that i live in and you know let the
cards play as they will get but but it's
democrats who don't do that and that's
why we have to make it really really
difficult in traditionally black areas
for people to vote we have to in in
traditionally christian uh evangelical
black areas we have to eliminate sunday
voting altogether because it's not just
about church groups actually bringing
their congregants to vote together it's
about somehow Democrats and brown people
committing the exact type of voter fraud
that it
years that Steve banning himself
co-manager of the Donald Trump campaign
is committed committing truly truly
stunning and I hope at some point we get
an explanation about this and by the way
Trump spokesman jason miller it seems
that Trump has a history of making up
people whose last names are Miller to
function as spokespeople I'm not saying
that's going on with Jason Miller it's
very possible that Jason Miller really
exists but back when we talked about
that other fake non-existent Trump
spokesperson it was not not Bill Miller
but it was another Miller and it would
just be hilarious if yet again we have a
fake Trump campaign spokesperson for I
would assume at this point that Jason
Miller is a real person but just funny
that yet again that last name pops up
let's take a break fantastic interview
coming up next